موجه احتجاجا عارمه تشهدها شوارع العاصمه
باريس احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد هذه
الموجه هي الاولى من ثلاث موجات ستكون
الثانيه الاسبوع المقبل وتستمر ليومين اما
الثالثه فستكون في السادس من شهر فبراير
وستمر
لثلاثه ايام هذا التحرك كان وليد اتفاق
بين ثمان نقبات عماليه دعمته جبهه يساري
موحده ضمت كل الاحزاب وتواجد ممثلوها في
الشارع ما جعل صوره تظاهرات استثنائيه
ونادره واعترفت الشرطه بانها مليونيه
الصغار انا متقاعد في الاصل لكن اتمنى ان
يحصل اطفال على التقاعد نفسه الذي حصل
عليه
وكما جرت العاده سرعان ما تحولت الشوارع
الى ساحه مواجهه عندما حاولت الشرطه تقسيم
الموكب الضخم الى مواكب يسهل تفريقها
محاوله اثارت غضب مجموعات شبابيه فرقتها
الشرطه بالغاز المسيء للدموع وباعتقال بعض
افرادها واصابه اخرين نقل بعضهم الى الحجز
رغم اصاباتهم
حب الدخل المحدود يعيشون حياه صعبه باجازه
محدوده ولديهم تقاعد باس هذا غير عادل
ولهذا السبب انا هنا اليوم
الفرنسيين في الشارع حكومته لاخذ خطوه الى
الوراء ذلك فعلته حكومه جاك شيراك عام
1995 عندما فكر الرئيس الراحل برفع سن
التقاعد لكن الحكومه الحاليه اعلنت مسبقا
انها لن تتراجع
فايده العربيه باريس